hey folks welcome to a very special
breakout from our episode lobby that we
recorded up at PAX Prime 2015 and sadly
as you may have heard the video for that
got broken as somewhere along the way
just saw when bra and they came out and
then all of his left was audio I
marrakesh managed to piece out audio
together six and hot b roll on it which
is what you're just the best watch so
the following conversation is between
myself Mike my hardy Rob handlery and
kind of funnies Greg Miller that micro
transactions in triple-a games are they
ruining them hey welcome back the facts
Greg Miller's here everyone hey do me
the honor of at least saying my company
and calm you introduce everybody else
this guy's from giant bomb this guy's
from GameSpot that's calling yeah but
you guys are [ __ ] everywhere now
we're not here i'll make my waiter then
rob handlers gang spots are you see you
there Mike Marley from video games com I
want that time and it's greg miller from
kind of funny calm
god forbid I get 1-click out of this
thing you guys are your beyond websites
you on YouTube I'd love to see Levi
excited ioio pair Snyder and nickel
every time I said you're on everything
and you've been busy all packs as well
yeah we've ourselves out a lot yeah so
yeah we run around you so I had five
panels yesterday Dane really that's a
record for me she's aight i was on a
live stream oh my gooood I know what was
the best panel Iran oh you were me live
streaming about metal gear without metal
gear of course oh yeah that was great
mmhmm yeah sorry they're like oh well
totally look we're to do this first ever
live stream with a metal gear solid 5
Grego gets a plane will be great my
great we get there and like where's the
game and they're like Kaname stuck in
traffic so for 30 minutes I just talked
about metal your side bucket is the
start of the show and it's like we're
gonna do or but I out gameplay then get
right I think you said as if you did I
open it up and I'm like if you needed
another reason to hate Konami if you
don't if you need another one as well
michael jones action said that's what
we're here to talk about as well let's
talk about first of all let's talk about
the metal gear solid mech
microtransactions cuz there was some
sort of like like miscommunication about
like what exactly they were so there's
the online component auth metal gear
online but the Forward Operating Base
yes the place is player a part of Santa
Bay correct that has microtransactions
of some account yes some kind yes you
might ask me you'd say hi Greg yes give
it Roy this thing for a week ain't you
got now can I say can you at least do in
my here's one that's [ __ ] spot on
Irish
getting more Irish today anyways and
you'd ask me about I'll you played that
for a week don't you know all about this
and be like I should but no because they
made us play offline which meant that we
couldn't play forward operating base on
the console we were playing on which
meant then we want to play forward
operating base we went to a series of
consoles that were connected together
like a local part I got a Deb unit yeah
and played in there so at no point was
there any mention of oh you need these
tokens and you need this to do that Bob
wha so when Peter put up a story the
other day and it was like you have to
spend real money on top of the fifty or
sixty dollars you've already spent to
open up fo b I was like that sucks and
then it got updated it's like that's not
the case it was like wow really confused
is that I see here at wit my thumb's
wait one day for this thing to be online
to me to see what it so we can finally
say yes so apparently what the story is
is that you do collect these mb units I
guess that you can use to unlock some of
the aspects of the player before tires
nice okay but the fact that I guess what
we're talking about today is the fact
that like why are even Micah
transsexuals in here like this is a you
know it's a I'm sure it filled you've
played a bunch of it i'm sure it feels
like it was worth sixty dollars but that
wasn't percent yeah does the fact that
there is micro transactions in this game
just it's just kind of [ __ ]
irritating every time this comes up
right i mean here's the thing i think
that micro transactions have gotten a
bad rap I think that micro transactions
are being judged as something that are
terrible without ever experiencing what
they are whose I'm withholding judgment
on phantom pain until I get in there and
know what the micro transactions because
the thing I I took away from it talked
about in my review on youtube.com / meta
funny Jesus close is the fact that the
game I could easily see being knocked
for being too big there's too much to
you'll never see and if it's like The
Witcher scenario right right so if the
porn operating base thing is like hey
you want to play this you want to be
competitive well you can buy this
booster you can do this or we not I mean
that kind of thing and not play I'm 62
hours in and having started that bow be
so I have as much you know however many
left to do like that doesn't grind my
gears yet when we get in there it's like
to play the game you need to pay then
it's like yeah this sucks yeah but I
don't want to judge if I'm edit and Mike
this is also crept up recently I
remember would halo and the two you guys
are big Halo fans as well so halo 5
multiplayer is going to have
microtransactions yeah again purely
cosmetic stuff cuz I real there's no
it's going to be like you first you hear
all halo 5 is going to be free DLC oh
that's awesome and then it hits you with
essentially there are rec packs it's a
patient's thing so you get rekt packs
through unlocking ranks and just playing
the game in general but if you want to
speed that up then you can buy these
things oh really oh it's yeah so it's
cosmetics unlockable weapons skins and
side come but for war zone it is
essentially you know you you climb and
progress during a match you hit a point
where there you can use your rec points
in which case you unlock a rep pack that
gives you a new [ __ ] that's where you
then get to use your actual rec purchase
order to United's it's not really a pay
to win in that respect it's just simply
I mean operator win faster yeah well
it's like I'm able to unlock it but you
still have to like play well during the
game right today whatever it is I just
in that situation isn't it really the
rub that like the people who want to do
that and by that are the ones before
that it was kill anyway yeah well I
think I could unlock as many things
possible for five dollars and I was six
right exactly runs a lot of like GTA 5
online right like it's just buy the
stuff to get it faster yeah and with it
like just pay like a million dollars
they like getting ten dollar for a
millionth already picking Oliver yeah
and again what's really fascinating i'm
curious about is how quickly will i get
these packs these rep tax on my own sure
sure that was scary I just feel like it
looked between this earlier this year we
had if all right anyone here that anyone
here play evolved when it came out
all right are any of you still playing a
ball oh yeah guy like when that game
came out apart from the fact that it was
like had its moment the Sun whatever
whatever a lot reason didn't of
longevity but when her reasons I feel
like there was even many people who
shattered the first time was that and
it's so not turtle box ball but like
when that game came out there was this
big marketing thing about there's like
16 different ways you can buy this game
yeah behemoth pack and then there's the
multi plc and then there's the season
pass which has the other didn't dlc and
you didn't get that one with this and
it's just like I feel like with this and
we like with a bit like the phantom pain
and with your talking about head off by
but a lot of this stuff just makes me
feel like I'm spending sixty dollars on
a game but I'm still not getting the
[ __ ] full game you know yeah that's
the thing that I don't necessarily like
about microtransactions I'm pretty
negative on them in general i get if
there's a free to play game that you
don't you don't page sixty dollars out
of the gate you don't pay twenty dollars
you get the game you can play it for
free microtransactions could like speed
it along or you know you pay for the
content you want but i have a problem
with the fact that you know they're
making this content but so clear they
took the time to have it in there but
then they just you know put a gate in
front of it and you've already paid
sixty dollars I played a little bit of
metal metal gear and I again I don't
know much about the micro transaction
for that either no one does yeah and
it's such a like it's such a huge game
but still the fact that they're in
they're still just makes me a bit uneasy
like I'm halo 5 the fact I remember mass
effect 3 did that the multiplayer you
you could pay to unlock those random
pack happens and I actually paid real
money for one of those and I was like I
don't feel very well I did the tip jar
for fallout shelter because I just
thought you know what this game was
great sheriff ray yeah just why not go
for it and that's the thing i guess for
me is that they come up my life so
rarely that I care you know I mean like
Batman was the one work is like anything
else like oh we're gonna do this since
me of what it was forty or fifty dollars
for the seasons of past and every other
later it's like poo pah I don't like
here you go look at me like I love rock
steady and I love
batman games and it's like yeah like
you're giving me Batgirl on this night
Emma and I'm not going in like I'm gonna
get another eight hours content out of
this I more like here's thank you for
everything you've done I want to give
you more money because i love this game
and this franchise in the love you put
into it it's weird because maybe then
what it is is it has less to do what are
actual like it's like our own inherent
value with certain games because i
remember with the witcher 3 like who
wears played to win two three you know
many people played this game so many
people play this game would probably
didn't play assassins of kings of the
first game and there was just this
massive like wave of goodwill common
anyway i was talking too much into Vince
key in Poland than like they had their
whole like yo we're gonna make all this
free DLC and we're just going to give it
to be there because we get it like we
want to curry favor with people and not
like nickel and dime to me and that was
the thing of when I started playing The
Witcher screen I don't forget into it I
got into and I loved it and I'm like man
this is awesome I went and I bought the
season pass and I was yeah I will never
touch this content it was the same thing
I do with kings of amalur reckoning
right where I was like your game is so
much fun then hopefully I get there
maybe I don't but either way i want you
to benefit from how much i love this
it's you know it's similar to when
you're on twitch and there is the tip
jar right you already stuff yeah it's
like what you're doing a great episode
today so here's more money that's how I
look at it that's how you know I've
gotten away with it now of course
there's horrible examples with EA or all
these other people where it's been
microtransactions when I first came
around we're so terrible you know I mean
these pay walls were awful I feel like
we've gotten to a pretty balanced point
where they're not like beating you over
that when he's dead is the preorder
bonus yeah if you want this skin
pre-order at gamestop Oh anyone visits
go to target I can we at one place guys
help me out can i buy this day one
somewhere else you know to mean look
like that when was the last time you
bought a game in a brick and mortar
store of brick and mortars yeah like
physical have you ever heard that term
before no no amazon oh no what would the
last time um well i got well there you
go will be getting i will be getting
fallout fallout 4 okay because you
pre-ordered the that's it i miss two
points later cannot remember when you
pre-order pre-commercial did you buy
pre-order your lines on and now now even
using a game stuff Mike what was the
last time you went into like a gamestop
it like bought some uh I don't know
Arkham Asylum maybe it was a while okay
mommy's last I mean it that I bought
something at again
I would have been when they put Walking
Dead Season one on ps3 rights as I was
getting some I was out for somebody's
wedding and I bought it for a friend
that I nude what I've had in a deep vide
video okay so you're I went in there
recently cuz Christina girlfriend
decided to get rid of all her old xbox
360 I thought I was crazy just brought
in with giant bag and they're like
here's $12 hundred thirty games what you
doing it and then backwards too bad
Melanie comes have the next thing what's
up she was still like I don't care I'm
like whatever I get him off the
bookshelf I still have a copy of med in
2002 that no one will take I've been
trying to get rid of it just gonna take
you please no Hills take it's like a
fraction of a penny so they're like we
don't even want this it's I have a
nickname neighbor friend yeah I have a
friend who in 2009 in the gamestop I
used to work it actually he went in with
a copy of I think it's pro evolution six
or something so it was like two seats it
was like a season and a half old version
pro evolution and he went in and they
scanned it and they said one euro and he
was like so embarrassed that he said yes
mmk euro get the sake too shaky with
like this is your ok framed it on his
half yeah never again never again it's
like your first check your business am I
last question I guess we're sort of
seeing more of this it's like permeating
triple-a games do you think we're
getting to the stage now where like
there is enough of you know a lead on of
people who have grown up playing games
with micro transactions that were kind
of just too deep but they'll always be
around and like every space from mobile
to triple-a how does then I think so
yeah the thing is because so many
developers don't like it but publisher
above them is the one that makes that
call so I don't think it'll go anytime
soon I mean the fact the matter is right
the reason they exist is because people
buy them yeah if they were putting these
out and no one was taking advantage the
opera's they'd be like this is stupid
like online passes right like those have
been phased out because they were tell
me did not work right and they're the
opposite there's some guy who makes up
for you and behave everyone yeah some
[ __ ] right by 10,000 accounts on xbox
live is just like you're off more
careful Walt Oberg sorry mom yeah it's a
nightmare the whales do a Welsh accent
oh yeah oh oh yeah we've got there
clean a chimney got sapori happy have
you ever done a kind of funny made of
two friends no really I will come back
they'll tear you limb do it again now
have the accent now run like an Greg
thank you so much going on talking about
microfiche